out of all of the characters that Disney
got from Fox in the Disney Fox deal one
of the characters whose future is most
unknown is Deadpool how's it going
everybody it's Warren and yes
Disney seems to be having a hard time
deciding what to do with the Merc with
the mouth
bring it on one-eyed Willy
ooh yeah your bullets they're really
fast Deadpool is one of the few if not
the only Fox Marvel character that had
massive success on its own this is
largely due to his humor which of course
is rated R humor something that the MCU
has avoided for the past eleven years
and not to mention another aspect that
contributes to Deadpool success is its
violence which of course is another
thing that Disney really tries to avoid
so given this conflict the question is
when is Deadpool going to be introduced
into the MCU and how well according to
the most recent reports that were going
to break down he could be coming in 2021
before we break down this report a
reminder that at 550,000 subscribers I'm
giving away an xbox one or a ps4
dealer's choice to enter all you have to
do is be subscribed to my channel like
the video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain
you can also click the link in the
description down below for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch so according to
we got this covered this leak comes from
an inside source at Disney the same
source that leaked the details about the
Miss Marvel TV show coming and the fact
that even McGregor would be returning to
play obi-wan Kenobi which of course both
ended up being true and according to
this report Wade Wilson aka Deadpool is
going to be making his MCU debut in
another Marvel movie and he will be
making his MCU debut in 2021 now this
report does not say which Marvel movie
that he will be making an appearance in
but it does say that he will be making
an appearance in a post-credits scene
now if this report is true it's pretty
easy to narrow down which post-credit
scene that he could be making an
appearance in because we know all of the
movies for the 2021 dates the first
movie of 2021 for the MC will be
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings this will be followed by the Wanda
vision series Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness the Loki Disney
series the what if Disney series the
Hawkeye series and Thor love and thunder
since Deadpool is said to appear in a
post-credits scene we could probably get
rid of all of the Disney Plus TV series
because they most likely won't have
post-credit scenes and I don't think
they would introduce a character like
Deadpool and a Disney and Plus series so
that leaves us
three movies shang-chi and The Legend of
the ten rings Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and Thor love and
thunder now even though I would really
really enjoy seeing Thor and Deadpool
interact with each other you can
probably rule out for love and thunder
so that leaves shang-chi and The Legend
of the ten rings and Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness now deadpool
could be introduced in either of these
there are definitely going to be
mercenaries in shang-chi and the legend
of the ten rings the ten rings are a
terrorist organization believed to be
led by the Mandarin who better to send
to defeat them than the one and only
Deadpool now of course we know that
shang-chi is going to be the one that
deals with thumb but it wouldn't be hard
to throw Deadpool in the post-credits
scene while at the same time we know
that Doctor Strange is going to be
dealing with the multiverse we will
probably see many different universes in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and different realities as well
this would be a very easy way to bring
Deadpool in to the MCU and most likely
make a joke about it breaking the fourth
wall in the post-credits scene of Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness we
could see Deadpool come through one of
dr. Strange's portals and make a joke
about finally being in the MCU and
getting rid of Fox personally I think
this would be the funniest way to do it
and it could also be easy considering
the fact that the multiverse is going to
be heavily involved in Doctor Strange
but let me know what you all think which
movie do you think that Deadpool is
going to be making his MCU debut in in
the post-credits scene do you think it's
going to be shang-chi and the legend of
the ten rings Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness or Thor love and
thunder or do you think you could
possibly debut in a Disney Plus series
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below also don't forget to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel for your chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 again don't forget to
click the link in the description down
below if you'd like a chance to win a
Nintendo switch and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof